it doesn't have to end in a fight Tony
you just started a war
I could do this all day hey guys I'm
Phil Molina and just when I thought it
could not be more excited for Captain
America Civil War they released a brand
new trailer that pulls out like every
stop it could spider-man obviously
ant-man on Hawk eyes arrow
there's tons of new details here about
the story and the characters I'm gonna
break it down just talk about everything
that you might have missed I'm also
going to include some stuff from the
Superbowl commercials that we didn't get
to into and also after watching this
trailer I might have a really big theory
about what might happen in this movie I
also spotted something else that I
haven't seen a lot of people talk about
it and it might be a really big spoiler
but don't worry because it will warn you
when we get to those parts I if there's
anything that you think I'm missing
there's a very very good chance it's in
our other civil war trailer breakdown
video so check that one out after this
one if you haven't because that video
has at least as much information as this
one will but now let's dive into this
freaking epic trailer job try to save as
many people as we can
sometimes that doesn't mean everybody
you don't give up so these first few
shots show us an icy landscape and a
remote high-security facility
and right away there's some details here
to point out the guards patch that's a
Russian flag and it says Russia in
Russia so based on the look of things
here and just some other clues I feel
like this might be Siberia which is
pretty much a place you go to die it's
also I'm really hard to see but there's
a Hydra symbol on the back wall so maybe
this is a current or former Hydra
facility I'm wondering if it's actually
the same location of that epoch
two-on-one fight scene that we saw on
that last trailer that was also enough
pretty similar snow-covered cement
structure let's talk about the shot of
Bucky and this Winter Soldier armor and
different kind of mask it kind of looks
like he's being deep frozen here there's
all this kind of dry ice fog stuff
there's frost on his hair now his chest
plate this could all be related to that
fog covered yellow tank we see behind
cap in this next shot but here's the
thing with all that there's somebody in
that tank and it's hard to tell who and
I know you might guess that it's Bucky
but there's some reasons to believe that
it might not be that I'll get back to
you later but if we go back to that
shopper Bucky for a second also just
note his metal arm it doesn't have the
red star that's either because it hasn't
been put there yet and this is a
flashback to like its origin or
something or maybe it's been removed or
maybe that's not exactly Bucky but again
I will come back to this kind of crazy
theory later let's move on New York
Washington DC
sokovia
okay that's enough captain people are
afraid we didn't see this un-archive
footage of the carnage from the past
Avengers incidents shown to the Avengers
by general Ross who suddenly come up in
the world since we last saw him
Incredible Hulk and these numbers on the
side here they show the financial
damages but they also show casualties
here's the thing about the technical
definition of casualties a lot of people
think that means deaths but casualties
actually refers to the number of deaths
plus the number of people that were
seriously injured the reason they're
accounted together like that is because
usually it's the military that uses the
term casualties and when they're talking
about soldiers it's a little dark but to
them a seriously injured soldier is as
effective as a dead one so they just
lump them together and call them
casualties now the reason I mentioned
that is because if these numbers
represent the numbers of people killed
combined with the number of people
injured I don't feel good about saying
this but those numbers are really low at
least considering all the destruction
we've seen the epic Battle of New York
caused 18.8 billion dollars of damages
and only 74 people were killed or even
injured by comparison the real-life 911
attacks in New York caused 95 billion
dollars damages and there were about
3,000 deaths when you combine it with
people that were injured so casualties
it's around 9,000 people 9,000
casualties the Battle of New York is
considered one of the craziest things to
ever happen in the MCU and yet hurt less
than 1% of the people that 911 did but
if you don't want to mix movies in real
life you can also compare this to the
Zod vs. Superman Battle of Man of Steel
because Bruce Wayne already told us in
the Batman vs Superman trailers
thousands of people died in Metropolis
and again that's not just total
casualties that's just deaths and that's
measured in thousands so you can see why
I'm a little shocked that we're only
seeing 74 people were injured or killed
in New York 23 in DC and 177 in sokovia
but before you think I'm hating on the
movie I actually think these numbers
were kept low on purpose you see in all
of those attacks thousands or something
I mean freaking millions of people would
have died had the Avengers not
intervened
fortunately the Avengers aren't real so
that's also the why the numbers are so
much higher in real life but in their
world
they were able to keep those numbers
much lower in the comic books the event
that causes civil war the Stanford
incident that got over 600 people killed
and it wiped out a freaking elementary
school and just the way it worked out
the Avengers were not involved in
helping in that situation so that was a
worst case scenario without any
intervention from the Avengers 600
people died and a bunch of elementary
school kids yeah after something like
that it's a no-brainer to think well
yeah the government should do something
about this there should be oversight but
here not in the comics but in the MCU
after years and years of attacks or
fewer people have been killed than would
have been otherwise had the Avengers not
intervened and that puts us in a much
greater area general Ross and team Iron
Man might have had an argument that any
deaths are inexcusable and the fact that
sokovia was the worst one yet implies
things might just keep getting worse
captain people are a fruit so you can
kind of understand they're wanting to
add some sort of government oversight to
this whole superhero thing they're just
trying to reduce the casualties but
Captain America and those who side with
them they might not feel comfortable
pointing this out but they have a pretty
solid reasoning if they were to say it
hasn't really been that bad like not
that many people have died what I mean
here's like technically more people have
been killed by hippos aichi have been by
superhero fights so cap could really
easily argue that if it weren't for our
heroes doing things the way that they do
them the death toll would have been way
worse so maybe they should just be left
alone to do what they do be heroes get
off their back Ross anyway that's why I
think the casualties are being kept so
low because it makes it so much harder
to swallow all this governmental crap
and if the number said that thousands
and thousands of people were killed each
time I think people would be like oh
yeah no brainer dude do stuff about that
the rest of the scene we covered a lot
in our other trailer breakdown but we do
get one new moment I want to point out
when cap tells Ross okay that's enough
you can see that it's around the same
moment that Scarlet Witch can't bear to
look at the screens anymore and that's
when she's reacting to the footage of
sokovia and that's because it's kind of
easy to forget this but it's only been
about a year since that event and that's
where her brother died in fact I
wouldn't be surprised if general Ross
just called that out to rub it in like a
frickin dick
moving on
that's why I'm here we need to put the
check can we get our first look at Black
Panther played by Chadwick Boseman out
of his vibranium suit and he looks
totally devastated in the aftermath of
this attack on the UN which I feel like
is probably gonna be this movie's main
inciting incident I get into that event
in the other video but regarding Black
Panther we know from the comics that the
mantle of the Black Panther is actually
passed down to him after the death of
his father the king of Wakanda and if
the movies tweaking the origin a little
bit they might have made it so the king
of Wakanda is actually killed in this
attack or maybe he's a UN delegate
instead of a king or something but
nonetheless this could be where his dad
dies which obviously would have lots of
consequences but let's keep going
whatever form that takes I'm game I'm
sorry Tony if I see a situation pointed
South I can't ignore it
sometimes I wish I could sometimes I
want to punch you in your perfect teeth
we didn't get a quick shot of what looks
like it might be the raft which in the
comics is a high-tech island prison and
it doesn't actually normally have
anything to do with civil war because in
civil war Tony Stark actually builds a
new prison called prison 42 and that's
where he puts all the heroes that don't
agree with them and people who refuse to
abide by the new registration rules and
yeah things get very dark where he's
sending his friends over to his prison
the reason it's not prison 42 here in
this movie is that that's actually kept
in another dimension called the negative
zone and read Richard aka mr. fantastic
is a big part of being able to access
that place and yeah all of that stuff
Fantastic Four negative zone stuff
that's all owned by Fox so they're not
even allowed to use it in the MCU
we covered all of this and a bunch of
other things that will not be in the
movie version of civil war in a
different video all about what you're
not gonna see in this movie check that
out later but anyway for what it's worth
the RAF prison actually does look super
cool it kind of looks like a giant
version of a MacPro and as we learned
from Azkaban and Harry Potter putting
prisons out in the middle of a stormy
ocean is one way to trap very powerful
people both of those prisons actually
take their inspiration from Alcatraz
which is the real-life version of what
was once considered an inescapable
island prison now it's a place you can
just wander around with your family and
buy a funny shirt also the inside of the
raft that design is very specific it's
called a pen opticon and it was created
by English social theorist Jeremy
Bentham and what's unique about its
design is that it has all the cells
facing inward that way all the inmates
can kind of be watched at the same time
and because it's so secure but also a
terrible thing to expose people to they
love using this thing in comics the kiln
and guardians of the galaxy is based on
this design it's also the design for the
Blackgate prison and a lot of Batman
stories and in the Arkham games but they
actually use these things in real life
too there's like a few dozen of them
that are in use today
again it's very secure but it's a pretty
messed-up way to treat your fellow
Avengers who just disagree with you can
you tell I'm starting to lean toward
teamcap and just before I move on I'm
gonna point out that the discussion Tony
and cap are having actually reveals how
they're gonna frame this debate I think
they're modeling it after the real-life
debate over gun control with Tony
essentially acting like the way
people do after a mass shooting and
saying look enough is enough we can't
just let these things keep happening we
have to do something and calf is more
like a gun rights advocate that thinks
introducing legislation and constraints
is only going to lead to it being harder
to be a hero and to fight their enemy
and that maybe we should just trust them
to act responsibly I'm not gonna say who
I agree with in that scenario but
considering how charged a debate that is
in real life I think we're definitely
gonna see a lot of divisive 'no sin
movie theaters like between the
audiences of who they agree with also I
do kind of think I knew how I felt about
their debate but then when I equate
superpowers to guns it does kind of
change everything I don't know let me
know what you think in the comments
about just this issue as a whole but
let's move on I know we're not perfect
but the safest hands are still our own
okay so we see more of this tunnel chase
scene between Bucky and Black Panther
and cap and now since the other trailers
have implied that everybody thinks Bucky
pulled off that United Nations attack
and here it kind of looks like Black
Panthers dad may or may not have died in
that attack you get away and chase him
down here but it's important to remember
Bucky claims he's innocent and if he
really is yet everyone still thinks he
did it that kind of adds credence to my
theory that oh maybe we're not dealing
with the real Bucky but more on that in
a minute let's also just point out how
freaking fast Black Panther is he's out
running cap and he catches up - Bucky's
freaking motorcycle and if you hear when
he used his sharp vibranium claws to pop
the back tires just like Wolverine you
can hear the claws shanked out of his
hand okay but getting back to Bucky we
see this shot that is so freakin insane
we've actually first thought in the
Superbowl united we stand trailer where
Bucky tries to shoot Tony in the
freaking face like Tony manages to block
the shot but look at his face he's
completely shocked that things just went
that far based on his outfit I think
this was just a moment ago that he was
joking with cap about knocking out his
perfect teeth and then minutes later
Bucky's almost blowing his freakin
brains out now that not only shows how
intensely things are escalating here
since that was definitely a shot
intended to kill not injure but it could
also be I'm hinting at pretty obviously
at this point and maybe that's not Bucky
I'm not saying that I know that for sure
but I am saying that it would make a lot
of sense if someone who happens to look
a lot like Bucky is the one who's
willing to murder Tony here and also
that would explain why people think
Bucky is the one that blew up the UN
again it's completely just a theory that
it just made up but it would make sense
also while it's very cool to see Tony
quickly assembled a portable repulsor
from is like wristwatch it is making me
think that we're probably not gonna see
the full-blown bleeding-edge armor from
the comics that stuff is insane it comes
out of his frickin skin this still looks
cool though
I was wrong about you the whole world
was wrong about you next up we see cap
running through an exploding building
and the editing wants us to imagine that
Bucky shoots war machine out of the sky
but that's actually not what it is it's
definitely a weird blast that hits them
some people say it actually kind of
looks like the visions energy beam and
while he's technically on the same side
as war machine maybe he's not under his
own control or something either way this
all happens during or shortly after that
battle at Germany's Luke huffin Airport
so that blast could have come from
anywhere like everyone is a suspect and
considering that that is another shot
that in my opinion seems meant to kill
knocking him out of the sky like that
let me know who you think fired that
because whoever it is is not messing
around they're taking kill shots also I
still don't think this means war machine
is definitely gonna die even though I
think someone big will I'm thinking
actually about making another video
that's just about my theories on who
might die so I'll save any theories I
have for that let's move on they're
coming for you I'm not the one that
needs to watch their back
this doesn't have to end in a fight Tony
next we see more of this attack on the
Institute for infectious diseases the
eye-fi D and did you notice there's
these electrical pulses that are running
over the guy's leg and his chest which
makes me think that Black Widow is still
using that same old electric disabler
that she used on Winter Soldier in the
last Captain America movie also worth
pointing out is that Black Widow is
fighting with Captain America here but
she's running against his team in a
second she's also arguing with Tony and
telling him to watch his back it's clear
she's gonna flip from some side to
another side and maybe back again who
knows
Scarlett Johansson said something like
that is definitely gonna happen and
it'll be for very personal reasons which
doesn't tell us anything actually
also note that Tony's arm is in a sling
and as I looks like it might be banged
up here too and since he's pretty much
always got that black eye in a lot of
the footage I'm starting to think that
it's all from Winter Soldier beating his
ass when he catches him off guard
earlier since that fight is one of the
few times that he doesn't have a black
eye and if that is the case then that
shot at Tony's head is not just some
random attack that's probably the first
major attack that makes our heroes turn
against each other like the opening
shots of a civil war and again if that
person is not Bucky causing that if
that's somebody else then somebody is
really manipulating the hell out of our
heroes and I'll mention who in a second
also that moment where cap tells Tony
that this doesn't have to end in a fight
it reminds me of a really cool moment
from the comics we're in the middle of
all the action like everybody hates each
other cap and Iron Man pause from the
fighting and they have a secret meeting
in this underground location that kind
of looks like this and it's a moment
that is pretty important because it
shifts us into a much more serious phase
of the war I'm wondering if that's
what's happening here okay now a moment
that could be spoilery if it turns out
to be true but just to be safe I'm just
gonna give you fair warning and say jump
ahead to this time if you don't want to
hear any potential proof about any
theories or anything like that cool
alright you had your chance so here's
the moment that actually started me
thinking about this whole Bucky clone or
Bucky imposter Theory like I know I've
been talking about a lot but this moment
feels like it could be legit proof of
something like that so I want didn't
want the other people to see him in this
shot where Iron Man back hands cap and
he goes flying in the background there's
maybe cryotank thing and remember we saw
Bucky in something like that at the
beginning of the trailer and if you look
at that tank now it definitely looks
like somebody's in there if you like me
the first time you stared at that you're
like yeah look at his hair
that's Bucky in there definitely looks
like that but if you're freeze-frame
obsessed like me then you notice this
moment when cap is flying through the
air and if you pause it just right who's
standing right there behind Iron Man but
Bucky so either that's not the real
Bucky in that tank or that's not the
real Bucky standing there but this is
where I got that idea that there could
be a Bucky look-alike running around
maybe one that doesn't have a star on
his arm and if so that explains a lot
about what's going on here like that
could be who blew up the UN and that
could be who was actually trying to kill
Tony and clones aren't new to the Marvel
Universe but they definitely I don't
think I've been done in the MCU so I
have to see if they actually went there
I'm also fully admitting that I can be
totally wrong about this - like that
could be just a completely random person
that to someone unrelated to all of this
stuff but it did feel worth mentioning
let's keep going okay if you skipped
ahead welcome back quickly mention also
there's another spoiler a moment coming
up not too much to get ready to skip at
that moment - if you'd like also be
careful in the comments section because
I imagine people will be discussing
these things down there but moving on
more trailer you just started a war
okay lots to go over in this section we
see some new weaponry from Ironman in
the form of little shoulder rockets
which really makes war machines rocket
launcher seem so oversized like like
it's an old-school brick cell phone
versus an iPhone or something and then
Bucky and black panther go at it some
more but the coolest thing to note here
is that there's a massive machine gun
firing from a helicopter and those huge
bullets are just bouncing off of white
panther that's what happens when your
entire suit is made from the same stuff
that caps shield is then you get more
explosions got a which just totally owns
vision but what the hell is she doing to
him it almost looks like she's yanking
the vibranium out of him or something
kinda like how magneto once pulled the
adamantium out of Wolverines frickin
body but it also seems like maybe she's
just controlling him with her red magic
which would be still crazy cuz he's got
the freaking mine stone in his head and
if she can overpower that then she's
insanely powerful but it would explain
if she was in control of him maybe she
did make him fire a war machine in that
other shot I don't know what's sad is
that back in an age of Ultron vision was
the one that swept in and saved her and
in the comics these two are totally in
love so that's the case here actually
then things are much more serious than
just friend versus friend got lovers
quarrels here also if you look closely
you'll notice two things one this is all
going down and what looks like maybe
avengers headquarters you see there's a
reversed a logo which means I think
we're looking through a glass wall or
something but also too I'm pretty sure
that Hawkeye passed out there at her
feet that looks like kind of his arm and
neck so the question there is did she do
that or she attacking vision because he
did that or is that not Hawkeye that's
somebody else but I think it looks like
Hawkeye let me know what you think but
okay moving on to one of the coolest
shots of the trailer and man writing one
of Hawkeye's exploding arrows and
jumping up through iron man's fingers
any time people think of a man joining
the Avengers this always comes up could
he ride one of Hawkeye's arrows yes this
is such a popular thing it was the cover
of Avengers 223 we also saw in an
animated version and earth mightiest
heroes it's very cool to see it here but
especially because I love it when our
heroes use each other's powers and
collaboration love that stuff this is a
more damaging
act and it looks like because we know
ant-man could shrink down and get inside
of Iron Man suit so you might actually
be causing some real trouble here this
is also probably good place to point out
that there's a rumor that ant-man might
appear as giant man at some point in
this movie and that would also be
amazing to see especially as part of
like this battle right now like a
freaking giant just stomping and like
blowing things up I can be amazing then
we get a nice clear image of crossbones
and it's actually from the fight scene
that had pictures leaked a long time ago
but it is still cool to see it here I'm
still curious what role crossbones is
playing there's a good chance he's
involved in the plot to frame Bucky
maybe but also we still haven't seen
Baron Zemo so maybe he's working for him
actually in fact that's who I was
mentioning earlier could be just pulling
the strings on this whole entire thing
and we just don't know that considering
that the entire storyline there with
Baron Zemo and crossbones and all these
bad guys is still completely up in the
air and this is probably one of the last
trailers we'll get I'm pretty glad that
we're still so unsure about what's gonna
happen as long as they leave it right
here there's still plenty to reveal but
actually speaking of big reveals let's
look at the end of this trailer oh and
also this is the section that's gonna
have a pretty big spoiler coming up so
get ready for that today now fine don't
worry I could do this all day
at the end here we get a little bit more
of this brutal fight between cap and
Iron Man and I think it's in that
Siberian hydro station and cap says this
I could do this all day that's actually
a callback to the first Captain America
movie which is probably the last time
Steve Rogers felt like he was getting
beat up this badly but okay here is that
potential spoilery moment and I'm not a
hundred percent sure about it but just
in case you don't want to potentially
know anything go ahead and skip to this
time and I'll see you on the other side
okay for those of you that do want to
know if you watch incredibly closely
this fight scene here between Iron Man
and cap is pretty much just a single
frame here but if you pause it just
right you see a body knocked out behind
cap now all signs pointed that being
Bucky since we've seen him in this same
fight scene in the other trailer but
here's the bigger question is he dead
like he looks kind of dead and dead or
not look at that image it kind of looks
like maybe his metal robot arm is gone
like it was completely torn out if
that's the case he's probably at least
totally out of commission yeah he could
totally be dead I don't know let me know
what you think I think it looks crazy
let's keep going and hello again to our
time-traveling spoiler avoiders we are
picking up right in the action of the
epic running shot with the two sides
team Iron Man and team cap just charging
at each other full force I mean look at
team caps nostrils that is the
definition of full force there's a
moment here in this wide shot that's a
reference to a pretty epic cover from
the Civil War comics and I know when you
compare those two images it's a little
bit of a letdown that they weren't able
to get all the Marvel characters to have
a family reunion in this movie but
honestly it's okay in the comics the
main storyline barely features anybody
other than our main people and you
actually have to go into everybody
else's own comic storylines to see how
civil wars affecting them and I think we
still might even be able to do that with
the various Marvel TV shows but here in
this movie it's gonna focus on the
heroes that we've spent a lot of years
with and we're honestly probably gonna
care a lot more about what happens
because it's not gonna be too bloated so
I'm pretty happy with that anyway
did anybody who watch this scene and
kind of replace the music they were
hearing with this music
if you know what that's a reference to
you really get me
okay and finally the moment that
everyone has dissected to hell but that
is not gonna stop me the first reveal of
spider-man in the MCU alright I've run
out of patience underoos everyone I'm
honestly not surprised that they got so
much right about him like keep in mind
that it was very important to them that
they not come off as just another one of
the same exact spider-man we've seen for
years in the Sony movies and rather than
make him look super different and weird
like those supposedly leaked goggles
that came out a while back he'd looked
even more classic they went to the
old-school comics for his look yes let's
talk about the suit the ones that the
previous movie incarnations did always
had some elements that I just kind of
couldn't believe a teenager would have
added for instance they both had that
separate layer of raised webbing that I
can't even begin to understand how you
would sew that on like I always imagined
like a spider-man putting on a red suit
and then he's climbing inside of one of
those weird expanding orb things that
you get at the sharper image like this
is just me because I suck at sewing and
I can't figure it out but maybe they
were great at it but that's not even a
problem here because the webbing in this
suit is just sewn in as black lines
rather than some weird raised metal or
whatever the other stuff was it just
makes sense here the colors are also way
brighter and more saturated than
previous suits but also it's a lot more
colorful than anybody else in the MCU
even does like in the movies and in the
TV shows everybody does a muted version
of their colors but this is the high
school kid like a really nerdy one
actually he probably doesn't think about
subtle hues and fashionable choices he's
probably like red and blue those match
done the spider on the front is also
super tiny compared to the other suits
and it's pretty directly lifted from a
classic comics tube but also it makes
logical sense that a teenager would
design a super simple little spider
drawing for his logo rather than these
like epic stretched out versions from
before he's also got a utility belt
which is from way back it's never been
in the movies but it's a good answer to
where he keeps his web fluid capsules
you also get a great shot of those web
shooters in action if you slow-mo watch
the one shot that's from above cap uses
one shooter to yank at the shield and
the other shooter is tying
caps hands which is pretty cool also a
lot of people thought the suit looked
too smooth or maybe that the CGI looked
really bad I think it's a combination of
yeah maybe the effects works aren't
totally done yet but also we're seeing
this trailer in a lower resolution than
we will when we watch the actual movie
and if you look at the high-res photos
of the suit you can see it's actually
got like a canvas like texture to it
it's almost like a basketball skin let's
also talk about the moment that this is
taking place it's part of the huge
airport battle and it's crazy that that
is where he shows up because that battle
already seemed totally epic so now keep
in mind throughout the entire thing
there's gonna be Spider Man just in and
out - my guess is that he's gonna be
fighting Captain America hand-to-hand
after I thought about that probated
actually made sense that he's in this
fight in the comics there's an epic
showdown between pretty much everybody
and while they are spider-man fights
Captain America and it's a big deal in
that characters arc and they even have
the same moment where Spidey pulls away
captain's shield with his webbing so
this is probably the equivalent fight
from the comic it's actually one of the
best fights in the whole story because
Spidey has these amazing reflexes but
like I've mentioned before Captain
America might be the best hand-to-hand
combat fighter in the MCU so it's
actually a really great match and no I
didn't forget about the eyes in the
comics that bite between Spidey and cap
is taking place not too long after Iron
Man has given spider-man a brand new
suit the iron spider armor I don't think
this is the iron spider armor I don't
think they're gonna have that in this
movie but I do think that the same thing
is happening here like if I had to guess
I think Iron Man has met Peter maybe
through his scholarship fund that was
teased in the old promo he finds out
that he's spider-man he sees his old
ridiculous version of his suit my guess
is something that is like pajama
underwear that he made himself
and that's where he would first refer to
him as on the roof and then Tony Stark
takes it upon himself to make some
improvements to it now which
improvements he makes are a big deal to
me because I think Tony maybe made the
eyes that can change shape though maybe
he did get Peters input on it because
they do seem to work mechanically like a
camera's aperture and Peter is a genius
and a photographer so he would know that
and if you listen closely they even had
a sound it's kind of like a mechanical
when changing everyone
so that all seems like the kind of
contribution that start could have
helped him with but the web-shooters I
don't know
will we see them here on his wrists and
their strapped on they're kinda like
teenager II emo cuffs I kind of hope
they let Peter be the one to infect
those since that's supposed to be one of
the ways that he proves what a genius he
is he figures out how to do this web
fluid thing and make its canisters but
we'll see how they do it oh and no the
eyes are not copying Deadpool his eyes
have always changed shape in the comics
and they could just never figure out how
to do it in the movies in a way that
made sense but I actually think they've
cracked it and I think it's a pretty
good idea mechanical apertures that
close and expand would be really good
for things like adjusting the ability to
see in the dark or helping you focus on
something far away that's how a cameras
aperture works in real life and that
said I do think that they'd like
Deadpool will use it to help convey
emotions on his face which was a problem
with all the previous versions of the
suit they always had that unmasked in
order to be able to show any visible
emotions at all but I do think it's a
mechanical thing here that they've
invented not some sort of just CGI thing
anyway I'm pretty thrilled with the
reveal I love that he sounds like a
young kid and that he doesn't take this
all so seriously and that feels very in
character for him and this trailer was
all around pretty great I think they're
in a really good place for this movie
and as you're probably hold off on
revealing anything else
you hear me marvel we're good you have
our money we've got all we need but if
you don't have all you need watch our
other video about the other trailer it
explains a ton there too and it goes
into a lot of moments that warning it in
this trailer also that video about
what's not in Civil War is a good
explainer for why you won't see more
Marvel characters and we even go into
whose fault that is share this video
around a spider web fun if you like it
and subscribe for more we do this stuff
always all the time to know about our
new video releases and news stories
follow add new rockstars on Twitter know
more about me Phillip Molina you can
check out my new facebook page fimo nose
and if you want to have tiny
conversations with me instead maybe
under 140 characters you can hit me up
on Twitter at fimo now I need to go into
a daredevil binging hibernation I'll see
on the other side of it bye